hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar combating AMR and bacterial
infections and investigating the immune
response I'm Susie Valdez of lab roots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Perkins Elmer to learn more visit
perkinelmer.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of our presentation and you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Nathan Archer assistant professor in the
department of Dermatology John Hopkins
school of medicine and Stephen Baker
professor of molecular microbiology at
the University of Cambridge welcome to
both of you Nathan you may now begin
your presentation
hello everyone my name is Nathan Archer
and I'm an assistant professor in the
department of Dermatology at the Johns
Hopkins school of medicine
today we'll be talking about our
research and infections inflammation and
immediate and how we're using this to
develop better Therapeutics in the skin
and Beyond
we'll break our talk into three
different parts today the first talking
about infection models and how we can
use them to test different Therapeutics
additionally better understanding the
immune responses of host defense and
Therapies
and lastly better understanding relevant
disease models of atopic dermatitis and
psoriasis and better understanding the
immune mechanisms that drive
inflammation in these diseases
our lab is primarily focused on
staphylococcus aureus and the reason
we're interested in this is because
staph aureus is the primary cause of
skin and soft tissue infections in
humans it has various clinical
manifestations such as impetigo
folliculitis and cellulitis
additionally
staphoric skin infections can lead to
invasive and life-threatening infections
such as Orthopedic implant infections
and sepsis
antibiotic resistance has been rising
ever since the onset of antibiotics such
as penicillin
additionally a recent study in landsate
found that greater than 50 percent of
clinical isolates are now
methicillin-resistant staph aureus
strains
moreover staphylococcus aureus is now
the second leading cause of deaths
associated with antibiotic resistant
infections highlighting the importance
of understanding the immune responses
against this skin pathogen
that antibiotic resistance is outpacing
the development of Novel antibiotics and
all current vaccine trials have failed
to date including the study by Merck
which found that it vaccinated
individuals had higher mortality rates
than unvaccinated individuals this
highlights the need for the development
of alternative treatment options
our lab is using different strategies
for the development of Novel
Therapeutics against staphoric skin
infections including the use of new
antibiotics as in partnership with the
TB Alliance
the use of new vaccines as we are
working with integrated Biotherapeutics
on a multi-component toxoid vaccine
and lastly better understanding the
immune responses that are protective
against staph aureus infections for the
development of host directive
immune-based Therapies
our lab uses different staph aureus
infection models including skin
infection models and Orthopedic implant
Associated infection models where we use
a bioluminescent strain of
community-associated
methicillin-resistant staph aureus and
in fact B6 mice and track these mice
over time using an avivo Imaging system
developed by Perkin Elmer to quantify
the bacterial burden over time in the
same animal
and as you can see in the bottom right
this is a representative image of a skin
infection where you can see the
bioluminescent bacteria in the skin
in this first study we are interested in
understanding the efficacy of a novel
antibiotic called TBI 223 which is in
the same family as the nasalid and we
were interested in testing TBI 223
because it's reported to have reduced
cytotoxicity compared to linasalid which
is typically used for treatment of
staphoids infections
and what we did is did a head-to-head
study comparing efficacy of TBI 223 to
the nasalid in a staph aureus skin
infection model
and as you can see using the biomedicine
strain of staph aureus that both
antibiotics have reduced bacterial
burden compared to shamtruder controls
and that they had similar efficacy
between TBI and the nasalid treated
animals suggesting that tbi-223 is in
fact efficacious against staph aureus
skin infections
and to confirm these results
we perform cfu counts and found that a
similar pattern emerged where there was
reduced significance in the bacterial
burdens and antibiotic treated animals
compared to Sham control
in this next study our collaborators at
Johns Hopkins use pet scans in patients
with infected bone to see whether
Rifampin antibiotic could penetrate
effectively into the bone if this could
explain why
infections in bone are difficult to
treat with antibiotics
and what they found is over time that
there's a significant amount of
antibiotic buildup in the liver and
initial buildup in the plasma that's
reduced over time but interestingly
enough there's a significant reduction
in the amount of antibiotics that are
found in the infected and unaffected
bone suggesting that a reason that
antibiotics may not be very effective in
bone infections is the low penetration
into the bone tissue
additionally they found that if you
increase the rampant concentration in an
animal model that you get a significant
increase in the penetration of Orphan
concentrations into the bone suggesting
that increasing the concentration of
antibiotics may be more effective means
of treating antibiotic infections in the
current doses given
given this information where you're
interested in testing whether we could
shorten the standard care of antibiotic
course with a higher dose of Rifampin to
do this we use the mouse model of
Orthopedic implant Associated infection
where we gave one group Vancomycin for
six weeks another group standard
Rifampin with Vancomycin for six weeks
and another group with high dose
Rifampin with Vancomycin for four weeks
what we found is that both vancomycin
and Rifampin combination therapies have
significant reductions in bacterial
burden compared to Vancomycin alone
this suggested that increasing the dose
of Rifampin allowed us to shorten the
course of antibiotics
in a standard care model
another exciting treatment modality is
the use of antibiotic coated implants
in this study We performed Orthopedic
implant Associated infections in rabbits
the rabbits were given and in Plants
either coated with antibiotics or
without antibiotics
and as you can see wraps that were given
the linasolid Rifampin combination
therapy on the implant had significant
reductions in bacterial burden than
those that were not coated with
antibiotics suggesting that this is an
exciting new treatment for Orthopedic
implant Associated infections
our lab is also interested in studying
the host defense responses against
staphoric skin infections upon a staph
aureus skin infection there's an
initially recruitment of innate immune
cell such as dendritic cells macrophages
and neutrophils to the site of the
infection
these innate immune cells release il-1
Alpha il1 Beta il-6 And il-23
these innate cytokines promote the
development of il-17 responses from gem
delta T cells into 17 cells
il-17 acts on keratinocytes to promote
the production of cytokines chemokines
that help to promote neutrophil
Recruitment and neutrophilic abscess
formation that's important for the
containment and eventual clearance of
the staph aureus skin infection
to help us better understand their
immune responses against staph aureus
skin infections we use fluorescent
reporter strains of mice that have
either a TD tomato gfp or citrine under
the promoters of il-17a il-17f and ASC
this allows us to visualize the
expression of these cytokines and
inflammasome components upon the staph
aureus skin infection allows us to
quantify the expression and understand
the kinetics of when these cytokines and
innate immune components are expressed
and when in combination with a
biomedicine strain of Staph four is we
can correlate the bacterial burn-in with
the cytokine response
for example in this study we were
interested in understanding whether T
Cell migration was important for host
defense against that for his skin
infections to model this we use the
il-17 AF reporter mice and treated them
with fty which is a compound that
prevents the migration of T cells from
the draining lymph node into the skin or
vehicle control
and what you can see here is by
biominescence there's a significant
increase in the bacterial burden in mice
treated with fty suggesting that T Cell
migration is in fact important for host
defense
however to take this a step further we
looked at whether this affected the
il-17 expression in the skin
and in fact we do see a significant
reduction in il-17 expression and mice
that were treated with fty compared to
control
we saw a similar pattern with il-17f
where we see a reduction in mice treated
with fdy
this suggested
that not only is migration of T cells
into the skin important but this also is
important for the il-17 expression which
is important for host defense in the
skin
in this next study we collaborated with
integrated Biotherapeutics which has
developed a novel multi-component toxoid
vaccine against staph aureus
and what we found is that vaccinated
animals had significant reductions in
bacterial burden compared to
unvaccinated controls however we wanted
to understand what were the immune
mechanisms of protection mediated by
this vaccine
to do this we used the il-17aaf recorder
Mouse and found that in vaccinated
animals there was a significant increase
in the il-17a expression in the skin
upon vaccination and prior to infection
compared to naive animals that were
unvaccinated or uninfected this was
rather exciting and suggests that the
vaccine promotes il-17 producing T Cell
influx into the skin and our next steps
are to identify what these T cells are
and are they important for mediating
protection for this vaccine
in this next study we are interested in
understanding the role of the
inflammazone and host defense against
staph aureus skin infections
as the inflammasome is important for i1
beta activation and release and we know
from previous studies that il1 beta is
crucial for host events against staph
aureus
to understand this we used an ASC
citrine reporter Mouse ASE is an
important adapter molecule for formation
of the inflammator cell
and as you can see here six hours after
infection we see a significant increase
in the expression of ASC which is
indicative of inflamasome formation in
the skin
however when we used a pan cast-based
inhibitor called qvd oph we see a
significant reduction in the inflamasome
formation in the skin
however whether this was relevant for
host defense or not we looked at
bacterial burden using biominescence
again
definitely what we found is that the use
of the pancast-based inhibitor actually
promoted host defense rather than
inhibiting host defense as we originally
thought
this was really exciting as I suggested
that pan cast-based inhibition could act
as a novel therapeutic strategy against
staph aureus skin infections in fact
when tested against pseudomonasaraginosa
and streptococcus pyogenes we found a
similar effect suggesting that this
inhibition by caspase inhibitors
was an important broad spectrum
antimicrobial therapy
next I'll talk about our Research into
understanding the immune mechanisms that
drive inflammatory skin disorders such
as atopic dermatitis atopic dermatitis
is an inflammatory relapsing
non-contagious itchy skin disorder that
affects up to 20 percent of children
most children outgrow atopic dermatitis
however three to five percent of the
adult population will have persistent
issues
there is a high financial burden and
serious psychosocial effects to this
disease
the reason we're interested in
understanding atopic dermatitis is that
staphylococcus aureus almost nearly
universally colonized the skin of atopic
dermatitis patients
in addition staph aureus correlates with
disease severity and highly toxogenic
strains tend to predominate on the
legional skin of patients
furthermore IG levels are increasing
atopic dermatitis which is an important
antibody isotype and allergic diseases
and has been found that staph aureus
promotes the production of ige in these
patients
so the questions we wanted to answer are
what are the immune mechanisms of staph
aureus muted ad skin inflammation
one immune cell type we were interested
in studying were eosinophils
eosinophils have various roles in the
body
they've been shown to be have host
protective roles pro-inflammatory roles
and immunore Regulatory roles
they've also been shown to be important
for protection against Health infections
and lastly
eosinophils are shown to have increased
abundance in the skin of atopic
dermatitis patients however it's unknown
what role they have in promoting skin
inflammation
therefore we set out to determine what
effect eosinophils had in atopic
dermatitis
to do this we've used an established
skin inflammation model where mice are
shaved and nared
staph aureus is applied to the skin
wrapped in bandages for seven days
after seven days the bandages are
removed and we see an area of skin
inflammation that mimics A.D in human
patients
the first thing we did was compared wild
type mice to eosinophil deficient mice
and what we found in this model is that
eosinophil deficient mice has
significantly reduced skin inflammation
compared to Wild type controls as
measured by disease score
additionally when we looked at the skin
by h e we found that there's a
significant reduction in the epidermal
thickness in the eosinophil deficient
mice compared to Wild type controls
suggesting that in fact eosinophils are
important for promoting skin
inflammation
in previous studies we found that il-17
was crucial for the skin inflammation in
addition in rna-seq data we found that
eosinophils were associated with the
expression of il-17 in the skin
to determine what cells were producing
il-17 we again used our il-17af reporter
mice
and what we found is that when we apply
staph aureus to the skin we see a
significant increase in both the il-17a
and il-17f expression as measured by
fluorescence
what we did next was took the cells out
of the skin and performed flow cytometry
for il-17a and il-17f positive cells
using the TD tomato and gfp fluorescence
what we found surprisingly was that
eosinophils were a major producer of
il-17a and il-17f in the skin suggesting
that the il-17 derived from eosinophils
was important for skin inflammation
to determine the human relevance of
these findings
we took skin biopsies from atopic
dermatitis patients and healthy control
patients and looked at il-17a and
eosinophils in the skin
as you can see in healthy control
patients
there's low amounts of il-17a and
eosinophils is measured by epx
expression which is a major eosinophil
protein
and when we zoom in on this we see that
there's separation between il-17
expression and eosinophils
however we look at atopic dermatitis
skin we see an abundance of il-17a and
abundance of eosinophils in the skin
and when we zoom in and look at the
merged image we see by yellow and white
that there's an overlap between the
il-17a and eosinophils in the skin of
Atop A dermatitis patients suggesting
that in human ad patients there is
eosinophils producing il-17
although we found the host defense
responses that were important for
driving skin inflammation in our eight
topic dermatitis model we want to
understand what role did staph aureus
play in driving this skin inflammation
and we got a hint from a previous report
by the Richard Gallo group that found
that staph aureus proteases were
important for driving skin inflammation
so we acquired an extracellular protease
deficient strain of staph aureus and
found that when we use this string
compared to the parent wild type strain
there was a significant reduction in
skin inflammation in our model as well
this also corresponded to a significant
decrease in the epidermal thickening
compared to the parent's strain
suggesting that staph aureus proteases
play a role in promoting skin
inflammation in the atopic dermatitis
model
however we are interested in
understanding what role it played in
driving host immune responses
to perform this study we used a mutant
staph aureus strain that's deficient in
10 extracellular proteases that was
previously found to be important for
driving skin inflammation
we combine this with our il17af recorder
strain again
and what we found is as before in the
parent staph aureus strain there's a
significant increase in the il-17a and F
expression
what was interesting is that in the
mutant protease strain there was a
significant reduction in both il-17a and
F expression in the skin suggesting that
staph aureus proteases were important
for driving il-17 responses
furthermore we took the immune cells out
of the skin and looked at eosinophil
il-17a and F producing cells and what we
found is in that the protease deficient
strain there was a significant reduction
in the amount of il-17a producing
eosinophils and a similar Trend in
reductions of il-17f producing
eosinophils suggesting that staph aureus
proteases promoted il-17 responses that
were promoted by eosinophils
psoriasis is another inflammatory skin
condition that we were interested in
studying
psoriasis affects two to three percent
of the population
and although its etiology is not
completely known it involves
environmental factors such as stress
microorganisms drugs and Trauma in
addition to disease-associated genes
such as il-12 il-4 tnf and il-23
stress cells are thought to release self
DNA and ll-37 which complex to activate
plasma solitary dendritic cells and
initiate an inflammatory Cascade
as disease progresses
there is an increase in il-17a responses
that promote neutrophilic responses
and what our group is interested in
understanding is what role neutrophils
are having in this response
it's been previously shown that the
antimicrobial peptide ll-37 and
extracellular RNA promote psoriasis
inflammation
however we are interested in
understanding what was the source of
ll-37 and RNA in psoriasis inflammation
our collaborators found that looking at
human psoriasis skin samples that
neutrophils were associated with the
ll-37 and RNA in the skin
to understand what role this had on
neutrophils our collaborators incubated
neutrophils from humans with RNA or RNA
RNA and ll-37 and it was only in this
combination of RNA and lo37 that
neutrophils reacted by promoting the
release of their intracellular content
in a
process known as neutrophil
extracellular traps
which are known to promote skin
inflammation and psoriasis
so for what we do next is we used a
mouth strain called lysome egfp which is
which allows us to visualize neutrophils
in the skin
and what we found is that when we
injected RNA and ll-37 into the skin we
see significant increase in the amount
of neutrophils that migrate into the
skin over time
and this also correlated with an
increase in skin inflammation as
measured by ear thickness compared to
vehicle controls
foreign
flux mediated by RNA lo37 injection
was promoting skin inflammation and when
we looked at histology we by measuring
sit 8 through H3 and NPO
we found that there is an increase in
sit H3 and NPO overlap in the RNA ll-37
injected skin
and sit H3 and NPO are markers of net
formation and neutrophils respectively
suggesting that when RNA ll37 is
injected into the skin it promotes
neutrophil migration but also promotes
the induction of net formation in the
skin which causes a feed forward
inflammatory Loop and promotes psoriasis
like inflammation
in conclusion we found that in our
infection models using in Vivo Imaging
we're able to test the efficacy of new
Therapeutics such as antibiotics
also testing various dosing mechanisms
to understand which may be beneficial
and lastly different modalities such as
antibiotic coated implants
to see what effect they have on
infections
additionally we were able to understand
the immune mechanisms in host defense
against staph aureus infections
this included understanding host defense
responses
and also the mechanisms that promote
clearance of bacteria by new therapies
such as vaccines
lastly we were able to better understand
the immune mechanisms that drive
inflammation in disorders such as atopic
dermatitis and psoriasis
including those driven by the host such
as understanding that eosinophils were
drivers of il-17 inflammation
and also what the pathogens were doing
such as proteases that are produced by
staph aureus in driving atopic
dermatitis like skin inflammation
and with this we hope that we can use
these new understandings into developing
novel Therapeutics against skin
infections and a Barren skin
inflammation
with that I would like to thank the
current and former members of my lab
integrated Biotherapeutics the
University of tubingen our collaborators
at Johns Hopkins Dermatology and our
school of medicine and various other
universities including Mayo Clinic
University of Colorado NCI and the TV
Alliance I also want to thank my funding
sources and perkinelmer for inviting me
here today and the audience of course
for your attention thank you
please email me with any questions that
you may have or connect with me on
Twitter and please stay tuned for the
next talk by Dr Stephen Baker thank you
again
ah good morning good afternoon everybody
from wherever you're listening from so
it's over to me
um my name's Stephen Baker I'm a
microbiologist at the University of
Cambridge I'm going to tell you a little
bit about what we've been doing with
respect to some work on our AMR and also
how that kind of integrates with some of
the Imaging work we've been developing
with perkinoma
so
just to change gear a little bit it's
worth kind of refreshing what is the
problem with AMR and why is this so
important I was fortunate enough to
spend 12 years living and working in
Southeast Asia
and there is a circle there focused
around Southeast Asia
which represents approximately a six
hour flight radius from one side to the
other
in that Circle it's pretty movable
around that part of the world it
encompasses approximately I mean I have
accounted them but a third of the
world's human population and almost
almost half of the world's animal
diversity so it's no real understanding
there's no real surprise that new things
emerge from this part of the world in a
fairly rapid basis
combined then with kind of animal
husbandry and we people believe and we
can debate this at another time about
the one Health Prospect of how
circulation and antimicrobes and humans
impact on on uh in animals impacts on
humans but also then in the bottom right
hand side there those are ciprofloxacin
that were bought within
um a mile from where I lived from about
10 different Pharmacy shops all for less
than a dollar with no uh no kind of
prescription or anything needed so
access is a problem and it impacts then
on generating drug resistant organisms
um what uh at the top right there is a
is an organism that's my organism it's a
staphylococcus that was isolated from me
and it highlights the importance of of
how AMR Works
um it was resistant to multiple
different antibiotics that I was taking
and in the end it was only susceptible
to one that was an oral antimicrobial
and I was about three days away from
having to go to hospital
um and uh and and have intravenous
antimicrobials
so I'm going to try and show some
animation if it works
oh very good uh sorry next slide so this
is AMR emerges because of this this is
the way antibiotics work they're
non-selective so they work like an
atomic bomb if you take an antimicrobial
they will attack anything uh that they
recognize as a microorganism whether
they are susceptible or resistant so
even if organisms are resistant they
will still have an interaction with that
particular drug therefore then we
generate antimicrobial resistance
because of this broad reaction of way
these broad chemicals interact with with
particular microorganisms
now I'll play this and this is an
example of why this is so important
so this is then at the bottom
um a diagram of the emergence of
fluoroquinoline resistant shigella
Sarnia in blue dots we have
fluoroquinolone susceptible shigella
Sinai over a timeline and in red dots we
have the emergence of fluorical loan
resistance you get us on the eye and on
the right hand side we have a
phylogenetic three of the genome
sequences of these organisms and then we
have on the on the left we have a map
and as you can see then suddenly we get
the emergence of fluoroconilities
in about 2009 it forms This Global
expansion and it radiates
internationally within the space of
about three years it's really tremendous
speed the way this becomes transmitted
from one place to another and it forms
sub clones so this is an outbreak from
that original outbreak in Asia in in
Europe and this is one where I was at
the time in Vietnam but actually the
vast majority of these actually
originated from South Asia and
particularly from the emergence from
India so Asia is a big problem and the
way we use antimicrobials
um impacts on the way they then respond
to to different therapeutic targets
and this is a problem and I'm happy for
you if you would like to go and read
some of my articles that we've written
about this but this also highlights the
data really nicely this is information
from blood culture infections from Nepal
over a 20-year period perhaps I think it
is I can't quite see maybe 15 years so
looking at the proportion of organisms
that were non-ndas and non-multi drug
resistant resistant to three
antimicrobial classes or more and then
sorry multi-resistant three
antimicrobial classes are more or non
MDR so less than that or susceptible and
you can clearly see with the different
groups of organisms so gram-negative
bacteria ground positive bacteria and
others over that period of time they all
increased significantly during that
period
and then as you can see then there's a
period here at the beginning over 10 to
10 years where uh non-mdr organisms were
more prevalent in blood culture
infections and MDR organism and they
track each other for a while and then
since about 2009 there's been this
transition and now this is continued and
now almost all uh organisms isolated
from blood culture infections in this
part of the world are now multi-drug
resistant
and we've done a lot of work on this um
really kind of defining
the problem and trying to understand a
little bit of how it emerges
um this has been focused really on
multiple different organisms but
salmonella taishi is one of our key
organisms that we work on in the lab it
causes typhoid fever
uh it's vital really for treatment of
typhoid there's a predicted 20 mortality
rate in the pre antimicrobial area and
we've looked at this over this period of
time lucky enough to work in a group
again in Nepal through a period where
we're testing multiple different drugs
for the treatment of typhoid and you can
see that the increases of minimum
inhibitory concentration of
ciprofloxacin or sorry other fluoroquine
loans compared with fever clearance time
so this is then shows why how important
this is that if you have a
drug-resistant organism or the higher
the mic to the organism to the organism
against gatty flux in the low floxacin
the longer it takes for you to clear the
infection and the more likely you are to
have more a severe typhoid and require
rescue therapy
and one of our studies on the left hand
side here and during one of the trials
we identified the emergence of a new
subclone which actually acquired
resistance or hopped into trial
participants during the study it was
associated with treatment failure and
actually showing that the organism that
you were infected with and the genotype
of that organism could actually predict
how you were going to cut your outcome
from the drug and then also then moving
into sub-Saharan Africa so these
organisms have originated in Asia but
then radiated across the Middle East and
then causing infections now in Eastern
Africa as well so showing that this is a
regional problem and then it becomes a
global problem and it really does impact
on disease outcome
just to take this on one step further so
if we look at the likes of ciprofloxin
resistance which is quite common now in
almost all gram negatives we do have
many Alternatives still or some
Alternatives but this then highlights
how this is a kind of Chase that we're
never really going to win
so this is xdr typhoid there's a fire
identity tree down the left hand side of
genome sequences a whole range of
different salmonella typhi there's a big
gray Block in the middle that says
Pakistan xdr so those organisms are
resistant to all but one or an
antimicrobial which is Azithromycin and
this is a problem and actually it's been
important to the introduction of typhoid
immunization in the region
um because the the who granted the the
introduction of the vaccine on the basis
to stop this outbreak of xdr typhoid so
these are remain susceptible to an
alternative drug called azithromycin
but if you look here we have Bangladesh
their acrb in Pakistan acrb these are
single mutations in an e-flux pump
which render those isolates there
resistant to azithromycin so it hasn't
yet appeared in the xdr strains but
actually what we're seeing then is now
the emergence of resistance to
azithromycin all the way across the
Indian subcontinent so India Pakistan
Bangladesh Nepal and we are essentially
one mutation away from having typhoid
that is untreatable with all currently
available or on antimicrobials having a
big impact then on the likelihood that
people would need to be admitted for
typhoid and treated with alternative
intravenous antimicrobials or not
receiving any Therapeutics in the
community
and arguably I would say that the thing
one of the organisms that I'm most
concerned about
would be klebsiella pneumoniae so
klebsiella pneumonia is another ground
negative bacteria that colonizes the gut
commonly but it's associated with a
whole range of different infections in
humans it can cause pneumonia but often
it can get into the bloodstream from
urine tract infections or from
colonization of the gut and cause fairly
unpleasant bacteremia it can get lodged
in the liver and cause a pleasant liver
abscesses and other things
so what we find is there are hyper
virulent strains this cause this
invasive disease these are not
traditionally resistant to
antimicrobials they're difficult to
treat because the way they get lodged
systemically but actually they're not
traditionally resistant to
antimicrobials and you can see that from
the plot on the left hand side so iuc is
a Locus associated with this hyper
virulent phenotype iuc Plus on the right
hand side there and they're generally
less resistant to different
antimicrobials however you can see two
groups they are saying esbl and
carbopening so those are coming from
India as highlighted by Orange and those
are organisms that are emerging in in
India that are hypervirulent so contain
the genes associated with hypervurence
Associated bloodstream infections that
are also resistant to third generation
teflosporins and also then carbopernoms
and how's this happening well it's not
the emergence of an individual clone
it's observed in many different sub
lineages so we see MDR organisms that
are crying the virulence plasmids but
also alternatively a hypervolent crimes
occurring the MDR plasma so this becomes
a bigger problem of the way these
different virulence genes and ndr
plantimoods can hop around be different
between different types of yellow but
also between different members of the
antibacteria
so that's kind of where we are and
that's kind of been my you know snapshot
of my part of my career for the last I
guess five to ten years if you like
um so now we're really in a position
where we need to start thinking about
what we can do about it
and it's a major Challenge and I think
that as with other big major challenges
such as climate change there are lots of
things we can do of which one of them is
potentially nothing that we can just sit
and see what happens uh and see then how
this pans out with the view of leaving
it in the lap of the Gods
the other thing that we're very good at
as scientists or microbiologists is
collecting data growing organisms
isolating them during genome sequencing
as I've just highlighted and that also
then helps us understand the problem but
doesn't overall tackle the problem it
defines the size and the shape and the
magnitude of the issue but perhaps
doesn't get where we want to go with the
view of coming up with alternatives
so what do we need well we need new
drugs
we need better Diagnostics to understand
how we use the drugs that we've got
better we need new vaccines
we need other Alternatives Therapeutics
such as monoclonal antibodies we can
think about how we repurpose existing
drugs by examining how they interact
with resistant organisms we can think
about alternative therapies such as
bacteriophage and other things
uh we can look at reversion so we can
think about how we block a particular
drug susceptibility Pathways and see
whether we can revert them but also we
can then come up with more kind of
conventional kind of clinical
interventions of how we reduce or manage
or introduce antimicrobial stewardship
programs But ultimately we want to do
all of these and I think we within the
group we don't try and Tackle everything
but we're thinking about lots of
different aspects of these things and we
use lots of different techniques to try
and add or generate data in these
particular areas
and more and we're keen then to think
about how we could expand this and other
groups are expanding what we can do in
this space to really think about how we
can tackle it
but actually what we really need is new
approaches that we can use not Sue used
to study and create new interventions
and moving on really from the more
descriptive microbiology aspects of what
we've done in the past
so one of the things then we've been
working with working armor with and
ourselves is then using this piece of
equipment which is an opera Phoenix
um it's it's really then generated for
studying um mammalian cells uh more
frequently but we've used it to then
study bacterial populations to study
them in great detail so it's computer
assisted automated microscope
um we can run it and we're running it in
96 and three at four Wells it's really
high throughput you can run 14 plates
per stack and just to show you know it's
like essentially for Imaging it's like
shooting fish in a barrel because we can
look at 200 sales per well and 80 images
per bacterial cells which really gives
us enormous amount of information so
then it ceases to become really an
Imaging problem or experimental problem
but really a mathematical problem
and then we have different things that
we can do about how we do use the the
assay about how we um look at the image
but also then how we use that
information and think about how we can
move that into using different things in
machine learning artificial intelligence
and other stuff so we're really just
getting going with this we've had it for
a little bit of time we've got a couple
of papers that we've come out but
actually we're really starting to get to
groups of how we can use this to study
uh bacterial populations particularly
with respect to AMR I'll give you a
couple of examples now
so this is kind of how it works and this
is one frame of some bacteria I've been
working with a I think this is a
eclipsed or E coli uh we can fix it with
uh different stains as you would do
conventionally with um
uh with confocal microscope and
therefore we can overlay them and do
nice things and then we can merge them
and then really look at different
binding patterns of different things we
could stain on the bacteria
um we use the software that comes uh
with the equipment to hone in on
particular individual back to your cells
and back to your cell population we
Define what we're interested in looking
at ourselves so we then look at how
these bacterial cells are structured
um what we're interested in examining
from them we can infer uh what what we
want to look at what we don't want to
look at so we can count like dead
bacteria and do lots of other nice
things with it and then then we get to
process the image data the other side
and this is kind of how it works then so
input the image we'd filter the image
look at the intensity of the organisms
we could select the populations that we
really want to remove the borders around
them then do the calculation and then
Define the bacteria and that then
produces a number of different variables
that we can then work on and put through
various Pathways that we're developing
in the laboratory now you may ask me
about these later I'm not a
mathematician so we're very much
dependent on working with mathematicians
to interpret some of this information
but it gives us an output of anything up
to 130 different parameters per organism
and traditionally we're working with
about 60 to 80 different parameters per
bacterial cell in one plane so it gives
us in fantastic resolution
and then this is kind of how it how it
looks so a little bit more about how we
generate that information using
different stains with the overlays and
seeing how they're bound with different
um proportions of the bacteria being
bound to different things great for
looking at how antimicrobials may
interact with the cell surface or how
they may impact on cellular morphology
or also we've been doing some work
looking at antibody Stone
okay so let's look at this so this is
one of the first things that we did
really
was to look at salmonella exposed to
different antimicrobials so we took a
relatively low concentration of these
different drugs and then looked at how
then these organisms then reacted to
these particular different
antimicrobials using mic concentrations
and we can clearly see then that we can
generate different cellular morphologies
by exposing these to different chemicals
which teaches us a little bit about how
these organisms are interacting with
these drugs and potentially how then
resistance May emerge by changing the
morphology of the bacteria and there's a
principle components analysis on the
right hand side they're looking at the
different variables pulling out about
how they behave and how they may group
together
so taking this on a little bit further
we were particularly interested in
ciprofloxacin because it's a really
um commonly used antimicrobial but also
then we hypothesize it has varying
impacts on cellular morphology on the
way the organism behaves and responds to
different antimicrobials we think that
actually it stimulates different
Pathways within the cell which may
trigger resistance to other
antimicrobials so we did it actually
comparatively simple experiment where we
took two clinical isolates a susceptible
and resistant isolate and two laboratory
susceptible resistant against
ciprofloxacin and expose them to four
different concentrations over a 24-hour
period and then image them every two
hours for up to 24 hours and those are
the images you can see there on the left
hand side that taken from the Opera and
we can quite clearly see that there's
some nice kind of cellular elongation as
you expose them to different
concentrations of the drug over a period
of time
so then we group this so then what we
did is then took that upper information
we took the 80 something parameters from
those organisms and then put them into
some mathematical uh algorithms to work
out how they group together and the
group together quite nicely so what it
shows then there's an association here
with the morphology about how the
bacteria behave regardless of the
bacteria background uh with their uh
interaction with the concentration of
the drug so the naught and the one times
concentration MSC are on the left hand
side and the two and the four times are
on the right hand side so as you
increase the concentration of the drug
that really has an impact on how the
bacteria respond and change their
morphological characteristics
remembering that then this is the
multiple different parameters that we
take off the Opera
but also then we can look at this in a
little bit more detail if you like with
how this affects with time and this is
probably less obvious but if you kind of
squint and you look on the right hand
side you can see more yellow in green
and those group together which suggests
actually again that again independent of
genotype of the organism the longer you
expose the bacteria for to the drug the
more they group together morphologically
using these characteristics
but why is this important why is this
remotely relevant so if we then look at
this again and look at the distance
ratio I.E the way these bacteria behave
through time we can see a substantial
drop off there at the 22 hour time point
that means they all kind of behave
similarly at that point and you can see
that actually those concentrations the
drug they all drop including the naught
times mic and this is really quite
interesting because what it shows then
is that these bacteria behave very
similarly at 22 hour time Point whether
you expose them to an antimicrobial or
not and then if we take that information
and then run them together and do a
cluster analysis we can group quite
nicely the susceptible and the resistant
organisms from that particular
experiment together without ever
exposing them to your to the
antimicrobial so actually we can then
distinguish the difference between
susceptible resistant organisms purely
on those characteristics we take from
the microscope would ever expose them to
the drug
and this is again what it looks like so
we can predict then with a collection of
different bacteria how this behaves and
we've done it with a number of followed
up from this using the machine learning
looking at these different algorithms of
what they are of taking those key
parameters and then we can then Define
using the information generated from
only four strains but putting it back
onto a larger collection we can predict
whether these bacteria are susceptible
or resistant to a particular
antimicrobial without ever exposing to
that antimicrobial and we can do this at
about 92 percent sensitivity on
detecting resistant capacitor strain so
some improvement required but what it
shows is that the microscope can
actually detect subtle morphological
variation in the bacterial cell that we
can't see with the naked eye that
predicts how it's going to interact with
an antimicrobial now this is really
interesting on the basis of them
thinking about how a specific mutation
in this case a single base pair mutation
and DNA genres Gene can an impact
someone on the morphology of the
Practical cell which demonstrates how
it's going to enter the specific drug
and this means then we can really think
about how we expand this into other
areas of machine learning and generating
more data not only to infer how bacteria
may be resistant or susceptible on the
basis of diagnostic testing for example
but also to understand more
mechanistically how these bacteria
respond to these drugs and how drug
resistance is generated
the last thing or the next thing that I
want to talk about before I finish is
thinking about klebsiella and the
generation of cloves a vaccine this is
enormously complicated and there have
been previous attempts using a whole
host of different things and methods
um and we've looked uh uh trying to
generate some of this ourselves using
outer membrane vesicles
but actually getting then a
cross-reactive response to them is
really really complicated and what we've
done is get together a large collection
175 isolates that we've characterized
genetically and performed a load of
different morphological testing both
both in the laboratory but also then
through through the Opera to really
characterize this kind of complex
species to understand how it may behave
with respect to an into immunization
and what we've done that is taken five
organisms uh that are representative we
think largely of of what's going on
Clinic with klebsiella of key sequence
types key capsule types and key antigen
types we've purified outer membrane
vesicles from them uh which are kind of
blebs off the bacterial surface and they
carry in a cross-section of the outer
membrane and then immunize much of them
and those mice have generated them an
antibody response and the question
really is that if we then want to
generate a collabsiella vaccine that
induces
um antibody mediated immunity what does
that look like against a whole host of
different cloves yellow pneumoniae
so again going back to the Opera we take
our bacteria we take our polycon
antibody we then fix our different
bacteria in this case 150 different 175
different types of yellow and then we
analyze the data to really infer how
those different polyclonal and serum and
bring a nice bind to a whole host of
different klebsiano
and this is then kind of what the data
looks like initially looking at very
limited kind of homotypic uh Sarah
heterotypic binding but then High
homotypic binding so actually what we
find is that unsurprisingly you generate
a really strong antibody response
against the organism uh the your you've
immunized from the omv against but
actually from others you get less
cross-reactivity you get some but
actually it's not as good as immunizing
with the host with the host ring unless
you look at here serum number four where
we get a really good cross-reactive
response to a whole host of different
types of yellow so actually not all omv
purifications from organisms are the
same and they do then detect different
things that may be more or less
cross-reactive against a whole host of
difference you get out of clothes yellow
which we actually didn't know before
and this is then how we're then taking
for training a model then of how this
may work and this is something that's
ongoing work at the moment and we
categorize these into different things
so here on the left hand side we can see
strong antibody binding against a
particular organism with a particular
serum we see mixed antibody binding
where we see a combination of organisms
that are bound and Unbound again
highlighting how important thinking
about bacterial populations are in one
plane these are all the same organism
growing up on the same day and they
behave differently with an individual
plane of experimentation we antibody
binding with a different serum and then
also then heteronymous antibody binding
we get these clumps and clusters
together and what do these things mean
and which ones are important for
immunization actually we don't actually
know but we think that actually getting
the most antibody bound to the bacteria
is likely to lead to some degree of a
functional response
and again just looking at how this works
some strong binding with another
combination of an organism some mixed
binding again where we get this patchy
patchy pattern of some organisms being
banned and others not and then also then
weak binding where we get bacteria that
don't show any any particular uh
prevalence for binding the antibody from
the from the Polyclinic server
so how does this then look so these are
our six uh Sarah these are 175 different
organisms looking at The Binding
patterns generated on the Opera Phoenix
and when we can clearly see them as I
alluded to before a proportion of
binding across the bottom that our serum
number four so from our own V number
four we can clearly so the most kind of
cross-reactive binding binding over 50
or the median is over 50 of those
organisms showing strong binding within
an experiment and others drop off a lot
less so now we're working on
characterizing what they're binding to
the composition of that omv to try and
work out what we're triggering an
antibody response to and how that binds
and what those potentially conserved
proteins or polysaccharides are between
those organisms to see what we're
actually targeting antibodies against
so making sense the data becomes quite
tricky so and there's a lot so we're
working with
um as I said we're working with the
mathematicians here at the University of
Cambridge to really understand how this
then Works looking at the portion of
binding organisms so we use particular
cutoffs so here of threshold greater
than 600 and a mean intensity of the
dappy stain to show that we're getting
organisms in in the plane of field but
also the amount of bacteria getting
bound and we've then done this across
all of our collection of 175 and now
we're trying to work out what that means
for generating cross-reactive antibody
response which may induce some degree of
protection against Clovis Illinois
so that really is then a snapshot of
where we are I was hoping maybe to have
more conclusive information but we're
just really getting going of
understanding how we can use this better
but we know then this is a major Health
Challenge which we need you approaching
we use a whole range of different
methods of which imaging has become one
of them really in the last 18 months and
actually allows us to see the unseeable
at a scale that's really unprecedented
so it allows us to generate data
um really that we're just getting ahead
round how we can actually handle with
the view of what we're trying to assess
but it has really and we're using for a
range of different applications so
looking at resistance mechanisms
studying antibody binding patterns and
looking at cellular localization uh
we're also doing some work looking at
functionality so we're trying to set up
assays for serum bactericidal activity
but also upside cytosis and looking at
blocking virulence factors and
multicellular system so we have some
organized models and we're looking at
whether we can block
um particular surface proteins
interacting with those and also then now
we're just starting a project looking at
killing and predicting killing using
Synergy of different antimicrobial
combinations
it's been a substantial effort and
investment to get to this stage but I
think we need this we're finding making
new discoveries fairly regularly it's
just working out how best to use a
technology and actually what I was
hoping to talk to you about that if I'm
invited back I'll talk to you next time
but actually using the Opera we've
actually found potentially the first
ever monoclonal antibody for AMR
bacteria so we have a really exciting
Discovery using a different organism uh
using the Opera Phoenix to screen a
whole collection of bacteria to identify
a particular monoclonal antibody that we
think can show some therapeutic for
potential but how we prevent or treat
infections with such organisms and
hopefully again if I'm invited back I'll
tell you next
and many thanks so the group here my
overseas collaborators my previous
organizations some links in with
industry and also then funding
organizations that have kept us going
for the last few years and I believe
there may be some questions and I'm
happy to answer them if I can thank you
very much
and I want to thank you both Nathan and
Stephen for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in
Stephen why do most AMR organisms
originate in Asia
yeah I alluded to a little bit in the
talk I think ultimately we don't know
the exact reason for it
um but probably it's just overwhelming
interaction of these particular uh
chemicals with humans and animals in
that location so the more biomass we
have in people and bacteria in one
location and more they're exposed to
drugs they're more likely are to emerge
there's other reasons such as economics
and other things in health cares but
actually probably it's a numbers game
whereby the more people we have in one
location the more they're exposed to
drugs the more resistance
and thank you so much and is a
cross-protective clivia vaccine a true
prospect
well this is something that's been
debated for some time
um our data suggests that probably not
so then it's the the it's defining that
that really individual protective
antigen that we can then put into a
system that allows us to deliver it what
we may be able to get to is a is a
platform that allows us to deliver
multiple antigens in one go but it's a
mechanism then of using systems like
I've just defined to actually work out
what those antigens are and how then we
combine them in an individual delivery
system to show them to immune system so
at the moment probably not but as we
learn more about how we can generate
protection using the type of things that
I've just showed you about it may
actually be possible in the future
thank you so much and I want to thank
our audience for these great questions
we have one more coming in can Imaging
be linked with any other data to infer
AMR profiles Stephen
yeah so again we've realized that having
you know not the to generate more and
more data for no purpose but having more
data is always nice and mathematicians
like having more information to work
with so we've actually been doing some
mass spectrometry as well so we take the
organisms we're just analyzing these
data now which has taken a long time so
we've looked at these organisms we've
exposed them to different antimicrobials
and different antimicrobial combinations
and at the same time we've imaged them
but also exposed them to mass
spectrometry and that then allows us to
look at not only then the cellular
morphology of how that may impact on
them to predict drug resistance but also
what's being expressed and what's being
shown on the bacterial surface as well
and we think that combining that
information really generates a kind of
detailed insight into how the bacteria
responding to the drug and how we can
predict antimicrobial resistance
Stephen thank you so much for joining us
for this q a portion do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we go
all right just thanks for listening
well I want to thank you and Nathan for
your time today and for your important
research and I'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Perkin Elmer for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand
laboratory alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
bye